hey i'm jordan alexander and i play
julian callaway
hi i'm whitney peek and i play joy a lot
i am eli brown
i play otto obi bergman hi
i'm savannah smith and i play monet de
haan hi
i'm zion moreno and i play lunala hi i'm
thomas doherty and i play the character
of max wills hello my name is emily
allen lind and i play audrey hope
hi my name is evan mark and i play the
character of arcano menzies
we are here with buzzfeed and we're
gonna take a quiz
that will tell us which og and
new gossip girl character we would be
let's do it
first things first you have to
personalize your constance uniform
what style are you going for sleek
sporty edgy vintage preppy polish
i feel like vintage sleek sleek nice
i said edgy i guess i would go with
sleek because i would say polished but
sleek sounds like polished with like
sacks in it oh
what do you mean i'm gonna do vintage
i'm a vintage sly
vintage i'm gonna say vintage as well i
ended up going for polished
that's not true though the second
question is pick an og gossip girl
character
you trust with your secret derota
vanessa
cyrus jonathan rufus or georgina
oh definitely i'm cyrus yeah he's a
lawyer
you can trust him oh i was gonna say
deroda but she's a little bit sneaky
sometimes so i would definitely she is a
blair
yeah yeah i say giroda i'm just
such a big fan of hers i know i really
am
i know you identify with her so much
i really do i'm gonna say vanessa just
because
i get just like safe vibes safe
environment safe space vibes
yeah that's also like a friend and let's
say like break up with him you know what
i mean
i would really trust my secret with
cyrus probably
cyrus looks so cute i know he's cute
you're gonna go through
rufus question three which nyc
landmark are you taking a selfie in
front of the post to your grid
we have the met the high line bryant
park
dumbo
dylan's candy bar or saks fifth avenue
i mean please saks fifth avenue i knew
it
i knew it because it's giving like a
rich opulence
luxury it's yeah jumbo
dumbo i see that for you cute area pop
ben
you know got some snacks yeah
something a little under the bridge i'm
going bryant park
i would go brilliant park as well i'd go
bryant park as well
go go so eli's dumbo i'm going candy
i would say bryant park i love a park
you're at an nyc
club which song is getting you to the
dance floor
super rich kids by frank ocean glamorous
by fergie
for you by olivia rodrigo watermelon
sugar by harry styles
thank you next by ariana grande or wah
by cardi b
featuring megan the stallion can i pick
for youtube
i'm gonna say evan goes to super rich
kids i'm gonna say that you go with
watermelon sugar
i knew you're gonna say that and you're
wrong and you're also wrong
how slow is super rich kids though it's
not yeah
the dance floor that's like taking you
off and taking the bet glamorous by
fergie
hungry no cat no no
i love that song i love cardi b by the
way
love love i'm gonna have to go with [ __ ]
[ __ ] is it you know i'm gonna say thank
you next
just because i feel like that song makes
me feel like like a bad
i know exactly i'm gonna have to go [ __ ]
um get me out there i'm going good for
you because i'm like whatever club is
playing
olivia rodrigo good for you like i want
to be there oh
good point pop dream like everybody
like where would you ever listen to that
in a club and
which drink are you sipping at
aforementioned club espresso martini
what's up dante
an old fashioned dante a glass of
rose a moscow mule a negroni or mimosa
old-fashioned nice i love coffee
so an espresso martini hondo peep love
that
then we'll go negroni they brought it
espresso martini
no doubt in my mind i would go with a
moustamia can we say what we think we're
going to choose
yes if i get this wrong i feel like it's
going to end our friendship
am i baby i think maybe like emma
some of it for you no no
no no here's the thing it's difficult in
class
well thank you for thinking of me that
way but i am a trashy person
i always order a mosque that's what i
was gonna pick
were you gonna pick that for me no i was
gonna pick a glass of rose
what what please you see a scandalous
blind item that you suspect is about
your bff
what do you do tell them asap ignore it
send it to your group chat
share more scandalous blind report it
lol you were the one who sent it in
i don't know i feel like i'd want to
tell them so they know that either tell
them or ignore it i can't
i can't yeah it depends on the severity
of it tell them asap
tell them asap you were the one who said
tell them asap like a good friend that
should be the only option
i know from asap ignore it
that's not a best friend no that's
gossip girl
last but not least pick an nyc based
show to binge watch after a night out
with friends sexton city
law and order special victims unit the
undoing seinfeld real housewives of new
york city
or gossip girl real housewives of new
york city i would do seinfeld i really
like science
i feel like i've tried watching all of
the above except for
real housewives of university so i'd
probably do that because i've been into
some drama
let's go with i probably put on real
housewives i feel like i'm contractually
obliged to say the last one
sex in the city i'm gonna have to just
go with my girls though
and say sex in the city i want someone
to make a compilation of just her scenes
i know she's gonna make that the show
i'm gonna say real housewives of new
york city because
after girls night out i feel like we
need to laugh
and continue the goodbyes
[Laughter]
you're the new kid on that steps sure
people may be wary of your presence but
once they get to know you you'll
see there's more to them meets the eye i
got max wolf in chuck
wow
talk about a wolf in sheep's clothing
you're a smooth operator who draws any
and everyone into your orbit whether
they want to be or not must have been
the housewives reference
i think that was definitely the deal
breaker i would love to be maxwell
for a day or chuck bath i mean punch up
that
i got a mix between julian and serena
i'm a leo this is bad for me you're
everyone's favorite it girl
with the heart of sometimes gold
at times you can be super sweet and down
to earth however
if someone crosses you all bets are off
after all
you know what they say about all that
glitters
[Music]
well you are very much an it girl so i
got zoey a lot slash
jan humphrey what interesting
you don't believe that i'm a good person
you know i try to be elusive i like it
you're very mysterious
oh oh you're joking
i am max wilfred
i'm julian callaway and serena
vanderbilt
bergman and nate archibald i'm gonna hit
lol because it's pretty funny i would
never have guessed i thought
i would get that one i'm gonna retweet
that lol and add four
i feel ashamed of myself
that was really fun make sure to tune
into
goss girl on hbo mouse
you